servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video heute mit keiner seite
und leute sind schon titel wir machen
heute eine ich habe noch nie junge du
hast das mädchen oder girl das ist
tradition
du bist ich bin wohl stimmt die bisher
gar nicht leid und die leute ja wir
fangen an kelly du vertrittst heute die
mädels der welt und nicht die jungs also
was funktioniert das dann ja wir kriegen
die gleichen fragen gestellt die
gleichen ich hab mir die fragen und dann
müssen wir antworten ich habe aber mit
diesem turnier schon egal was es kein
aspekt ist einfach nur nationen bei und
nicht nur allmend genau und will gucken
quasi wer ist von mentalität her
auf der anderen seite ok oder ich habe
noch nie das gleiche geschlecht auf den
mund geküsst
[Gelächter]
aber dazu dies soll an ihr ist es ja
nicht so schlimm weil ich habe also so
als genie und so dass man das unter
freunden
ja es gab doch immer so eine zeit wo
sich also zum zur begrüßung q-soft mund
gegeben ganz ruhig irgendwie so etwas
genau so nah bei dir die story gespannt
waren im urlaub und ich habe mich an dem
abend mit irgend so ein mädchen gehalten
was ich schon ein bisschen erkennen die
mit ihr geredet haben und fand die ganz
nett die für mich auch ganz nett und
janko mit von ihr das gesehen aber wir
sind nicht auf den grünen zweig gekommen
heisst also es ging nicht wirklich voran
weiter und verletzt da wollte auf mich
ich habe selbst nicht gecheckt in dem
moment und dann meinte er so ja wie
schwer ist ein spiel wir geben jeweils
einen kurs weiter und dann eiskalt ich
hab das war also wieder was geht ab
küsste mich einfach auf dem unten im
moment und dann dass ich sofort und dann
habe ich dann halt dann sie geben im
moment also eigentlich von der leyen
aber auch bist du ja und das ist ja dass
man nicht alles tut um mädchen auch zur
besten jenny schreibt ich habe noch nie
eine beziehung mit zwei leuten
gleichzeitig gehabt 31 zumeist ich war
nicht dabei
hast du auch noch nicht mal finde ich
krass uncool von die an der stadt
überhaupt erst überhaupt also ja schon
am morgen aber fall weniger aber
wirklich so beziehung eine richtige
beziehung also dass man irgendwie so
managen sind soja dated vielleicht mal
aber nimmt beziehung ok jetpack er
schreibt ich hab noch nie versucht oder
darüber nachgedacht eine beziehung zu
ruinieren weil ich auf einen von den
partnern stand und jetzt wieder mal ein
weiterer schritt von meinem weg in die
hölle die man hier ist der fall klar
nicht mehr nein ich darüber nachgedacht
nein ich würde ich nie machen im leben
nicht ich auch nicht die rede schreibt
ich habe noch niemanden küsten nicht
nicht küssen wollte sorgen kann ich
schon gehört jemand der mit wissen
wolltest ja auf jeden fall recht wie
passiert dass hansen ja dann denkt man
sich so ob es dann so später so die gute
landliebe milch wenn man da wieder
zweite zu viel hat das ist schon ein
bisschen viel kalzium für den körper
die liebe zum schreiben hat noch nie ein
video von bibi geliked mein gott hat es
kann videos
die bibel hat er das war schon krass
wenn du in video von bmi gereicht hätte
jetzt raus ich habe auch schon das ist
klassisch schwangerschafts wir gehen ja
das war ich ja noch hast du das
vorstandsgehalt bestimmt ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob entwicklung
rom girl oder hot luca gut schreibt ich
habe noch nie geld für etwas ausgegeben
was ich gar nicht brauche doch jeder
schon mal kleine also ich brauche alle
mehreren mehr spaß sollte hast du dein
auto unbedingt wohl zum e mail ein ich
brauche das auto zu überleben kann
einsteinstraße 10 78713 schramberg genau
das was glaubst du dir sowas nicht post
keine ahnung schuhe schminke brauchen
nicht okay okay nicht schreibt ich habe
noch niemanden besten freunde beste
freundin darum gebeten mich von einem
schlechten day zu befreien 3 2 1 wobei
[Musik]
das irgendwann passiert ist irgendwie
sowieso was sohn oder dass man schnell
was ausmacht und dass man sich nachher
trifft und sagte ganz vergessen ich
hatte noch nie so was machst du
also ich weiss nicht manchmal sitzt
menschen da wo du so denkst okay das ist
einfach so einfach ist wie du sagst du
sagst aber so wie übrigens auch ich muss
jetzt gehen
ich muss gehen alles klar china schreibt
ich habe noch nie mehr als rund fünf mal
am tag an den zwischenmenschlichen
körperlichen austausch von flüssigkeiten
also an dass leute ok warte man kurz wer
denkt so bewusst an sex somit zählt wie
oft man am tag an sex denkt sie aktiv
mit zu der einzige mensch wird weiter
wenn wir mal realistisch schätzen würde
ich auf jeden fall sagen
21 wahrscheinlich so anschaue ist schon
so ein bisschen 13 menschen einköpfen
abgewehrt ja aber ich weiss ich fünf mal
wenn man sich überlegt dass es auch ganz
zufrieden oder fünfmal so ist weil es so
eine schulstunde sowie drei bis vier bis
fünf mal eine stunde und 40 minuten
fünfmal es kein scheiß gerade ich hab
das schon okay das ist ja auch in
ordnung
ich hasse jüngst gerade wenn ich noch
eine nette lehrerin fragen hast dann
okay man munkelt solche dinge passieren
ich habe noch nie ich liebe dich gesagt
und das nicht so gemeint sagt egli das
ist echt eine art chor frage selten oder
nein das geht überhaupt nicht mit dem
ruhm schlängeln
ja also doch schon ich gerne zeit mit
dir verbringen
danke du hast du nicht eigentlich
ausgemacht oder ich muss zu machen oder
einfach die kehle methode einfach
tschüss r coacht seit dem ganzen tag so
sagt er so zu dir ich liebe dich und du
so alles hat also das was von diesem
video kelly ist natürlich die
beschreibung und verlinkte fürs
mitmachen kann du darfst jetzt einfach
mal hin angenehm sei gar nicht oder ist
super hast du dich die ganze folge aber
wohl gefühlt nein
okay das war's dann wieder leute haut